welcome everybody
my name is julian saba i'm with the
proteomics team at thermal fischer
scientific
and i will be doing the introduction to
our first speaker max
crisman um max reads biochemistry at the
university of oxford as an undergraduate
after doctoral studies at oxford and
scripps research
he went on to run on the glycoprotein
therapeutics laboratory within oxford's
department of biochemistry
bax moved to university of southampton
in 2017
where he is the professor of
glycobiology his lab operates in the
nexus
of glycoprotein engineering and glycan
analytics
and is currently dedicated to the design
and analysis of glycoprotein-based
therapies and vaccines
max's laboratory is funded by the bill
and melinda gates foundation through
collaboration
for aids vaccine discovery the
international aids vaccine initiative
the u.s national institute of health the
european union horizon 2020 program and
by against breast cancer he's currently
supernumerary fellow at oriole college
oxford and professor adjunct in the
department of immunology and
microbiology
at scripps research thank you max
so thank you very much for that kind
introduction and it's real
honor to be here today um i've been
invited to talk about some of my work in
virology and in particular on the
glycosylation
of envelope viruses and um i'm really
going to
draw on a lot of our work from hiv and
of course
link that to the developments in the
sars cov2
so one of the reasons we're so
interested in glycosylation is that it's
an extensive modification of
envelope vices so these are the envelope
spikes
of a range of different uh different
viruses
now the the the grey platform if you
like is represents the lipid membrane of
these
of these viruses and you have these
attachment
spikes sticking out of the virus now
these are critical
for the biology of the virus this is
what mediates the attachment to the
target cell
and ultimately fusion of the uh
of the viral membrane to the to the
target
now in blue you'll see all these
carbohydrates now there are different
types of carbohydrates today i'm going
to be principally
focused on n-link social
asparagine-linked carbohydrates
and they're attached by the host
cellular machinery
at a particular sequence within the
primary structure of the protein
now this is important because that means
the location and attachment points
of these glycans are actually
genetically determined
uh by the virus and what you'll see is
that we're very interested in this
in terms of their wide range of biology
but in particular
the fact that they can be used as glycan
shields
now i really like the uh
um image of the um
the sort of wolf in sheep's clothing
because this really represents
uh the idea that the viral spikes are
covered
by sugars that are ultimately self
so your immune system really doesn't
doesn't see them as
as a foreign viral entity at all but
rather
self structures this means they can
obscure
large parts the antigenic surface of of
the virus
now um there are a couple of exceptions
to this so if you have
viruses that are zoonotic so they're
moving between different organisms so
for example a flavivirus
maybe insect born they'll have sugars
that are insect-like
and you you can have antibodies against
these types of sugars that can
act as a bit of a barrier to the
transmission and this is even the case
in humans where we have blood groups now
blood group the base of blood groups are
carbohydrates
and you have these particular
modifications that are specific to
people
that are going to occur on the
glycoprotein but also the glycolipids
and this can even in hiv give a
measurable
hurdle to infection not very significant
but but
measurable but it for our purposes today
we can largely think of these sugars
itself
and offering a limit to how antibodies
can
ultimately neutralize viruses
now in the context of hiv
there are it's been really sort of
interesting
how the field has been slowly
increasingly focused on the carbohydrate
shield
now in hiv you have a virus that's
infected a patient
and it's sort of hiding and resident
within that patient
for for many years so that has
particular implications it means that
the virus has to survive under the
selective pressure
of the host immune system and that
drives a very high density
of um of these of these glycans here
shown
shown in green now the reason why the uh
the vaccine field is so interested in
these sugars is that
over time there have been about a third
of patients develop
so-called broadly neutralizing
antibodies that
can often recognize the carbohydrates
but
or at least to evolve to to avoid them
as well now we say broadly neutralizing
because hiv
the mutation rate is phenomenal and so
um you know these these antibodies are
actually capable of
neutralizing a range of different
viruses uh regardless of the mutation so
they're incredibly
incredibly broad and here we show a
remarkable structure by ian wilson's
laboratory at scripps
and this shows one such antibody the
pgt-128
but recognizing the target
hiv glycoprotein now
the remarkable thing here you'll see in
the antibody in blue
is that it's recognizing the
carbohydrates
in this case two different glycans we
call them
attached to two different asparagines
and it's slotting in between these
and making only minor contacts with the
protein surface and what you'll see
is actually those two little arrows the
blue and the green
indicate a beta sheet that's formed so
even the contact of this antibody
to the protein is not really driven
through side chains but through the
backbone
so this means the mutations that are
occurring in the protein
are really not impacting its binding and
therefore
it can neutralize all these wide range
of strains and this is
even true for glycans
if you were to mutate some of these
glycans often the antibodies can just
change their angle of attack and bind to
a neighboring glycan
so it's real these things are remarkably
uh have remarkable properties
and they've now as a as a field
identified
numerous broadly utilizing antibodies
that cover almost the whole surface
of the hiv spike
and here showing this nice little
rainbow plot a variety of different
classes of these
antibodies and their carbohydrate
targets
now why isn't this a solution for a for
a vaccine
well the problem is these antibodies
take a long time to develop
so whilst they can if passively
transferred
offer protection if you're already
infected they cannot
eliminate the infection because the
virus is too diverse already
and you know their mutational history
because they are evolving to recognize
self structures
means that it takes a very long time for
antibodies to
evolve so the real challenge then is to
be able to
design ways that you can elicit these
antibodies to target this
now our involvement is very much on
helping the vaccine community in
studying the carbohydrate modifications
of their immunogens
because if you're trying to make your
immune system recognize these
carbohydrates
your immunogens your vaccine candidates
you know they ought to present those
carbohydrate
epitapes in order to potentially elicit
these types of antibodies so monitoring
immunogens
is is really really important just
stepping back a bit
about more of the biology um
you know the glycosylation impacts
a wide range of different features of
the virus but also
we can learn a lot from recombinant
mimics and studying these recombinant
immunogens
so for example um the glycan processing
of immunogen
can impact um what can inform about the
integrity of the protein i'll illustrate
a few examples of that
it can also impact the trafficking
of the immunogen to the through the sort
of
lymphatic system and ultimately
interaction with your immune system so
they can impact the sort of
immunogenicity
of the protein and i've we've mentioned
about the presentation of actual
carbohydrate epitapes
and we can also learn a little bit about
the degree of glycan shielding that's
occurring across
these virus classes by studying the the
processing
now referring to the biology
glycosylation
impacts extensive
areas of viral biology permeates um
a lot of the interactions between the
virus and the host
now here we've just included one one
example
of a viral glycoprotein being
being manufactured by the producer cell
and incorporating the virus
and you'll see a recurring theme here is
i'm using a color code
to show early sugars that are
placed on the er showing in green these
are sort of oligomenos forms
and as the protein gets produced
and secreted through the golgi you get
more more collaborations
and we're we're depicting those in a
magenta color
to illustrate you know processing and
you will immediately see an example
we've chosen
that viruses have a mix of this green
and magenta
meaning some of the sugar structures
that are present in the art are getting
produced and actually added onto the
virus now this is a really quite
important feature
because your immune system is geared up
to recognize these mannose structures
yeast have manans
you know chemically the same thing you
have host lectins designed
to recognize mannose as a sort of
inflammatory signal
and um it's really interesting that in
mice that have been engineered
to display nanos on their their self
cells
uh they have chronic activation in the
innate immune system
so there's a big pressure on your own
glycoproteins
not to display manners whereas in
viruses
they have such a high density of sugars
that this leads to these manus features
appearing and in fact it's a
double-edged thing in one way
these the prince of nanos can be used to
recognize potentially
neutralize viruses by the immune system
but they can also be exploited by the
virus in infecting those very cells that
display those lectins
so it's a really quite uh complicated
area
of of biology so just to reiterate
in terms of the pathway because we will
be showing the
sort of some of the sugar structures
present on these glycoproteins
the the proteins are made within the er
now one of the selective pressures for
viruses to have lots of sugars
is to help folding so there's a folding
pathway that utilizes the
the the sugars then they are and then
you get this series of reactions
uh trimming of mannoses and building up
of more
of other residues like galactoses and
xylic acid and
we describe those as sort of complex
type glycans
now importantly and this is an example
from my early antibody work
you can trap the biosynthesis
artificially using inhibitors or mutants
and we've studied here the sugars by
basic mass spectrometry here and it
shows the
um homogeneity of the early stages of
this pathway
and it's only really when you get to the
golgi that you get this complexification
occurring now returning back onto what
we can learn about studying
glycosylation of recombinant proteins
and this is where i begin to include
some of the work on the sars cov2
we've already and this has been
remarkable to me
they've been identified antibodies that
have been identified
that can actually recognize um
carbohydrate components
so here on on the left you'll see
a antibody that recognizes both the
protein but also a fucose residue
present on the viral glycoprotein
now this is quite interesting because
what this means
is the recombinant proteins are being
able to have carbohydrate processing
events that can be
can be um recognized by by the host
immune response
so we already have a pretty good
indication that
recombinant systems can capture some of
the features
of um authentic infectious viruses
and in fact there's already been quite a
few studies i've highlighted a couple
here
showing that in the sars there's been
uh the viruses present a mixture of
complex glycans
and and sort of all again manners once
now this is really quite important
because it wasn't obvious that this was
going to be the case
chrome devices actually bud into the
secretary system rather than budding
from the plasma membrane like is the
case in hiv so what impact could that
have
on on glycogen processing and actually
the the evidence is very strongly that
you do get
pretty normal maturation events and i've
made a little note here
that i will be uh showing some
remarkable data by
psy lee um
and his his work um on the native
authentic
virus very excited to see that so
the other thing of course is i mentioned
that the recombinant proteins
when used as vaccine candidates uh their
glycosylation state can affect the
trafficking of your
your real global protein within your
your immune system and
that is obviously it's really linked to
the elicitation of our antibody response
and that's been beautifully demonstrated
by
daryl ervin's group in mit um and that
was published in science in
2019 so what lessons can we learn
from hiv
now what we have there is
a lipid
lipid virion with only a small number of
spikes
protruding but these are sort of
trimeric spikes
heavily glycosylated and what we've
shown
and here is just some uplc data
fluorescently linked
of glycans have been released from these
glycoproteins
what um we and others have shown is that
native like glycoproteins actually
present
more oligomonos so the top is just the g
prime20 subunits
and that has like a third third
oligomenose if you artificially
trimmerize these um these glycoproteins
and sort of pseudotrimer you basically
don't lead
to a big elevation it's only when you
have native like
um folds where you get this elevation of
oligomelas
so that's sort of what i was talking
about about this relationship
between protein integrity and protein
confirmation
and the impact on trimming now
we've been investigating this on a site
specific level doing glycopeptide mass
spectrometry
and our first um when we first dipped
our toe in the water
than this was in somewhere published in
2016 so comparably recently
and at the time the hiv literature was a
bit confusing
so depending on the methodologies that
were employed
you'd get a different sort of um readout
of quantitation
and you know often they wouldn't quite
agree with
what we'd know about the appetites based
on neutralization assays with
carbohydrate-specific antibodies so i
was a bit
nervous about uh how to approach this so
we went uh
back to some pretty old-fashioned
methods we isolated glycopeptides
fractions uh by reverse phase hplc and
we studied those fractions
of the hiv glycoprotein by different
methods moldy
chopping the sugars off and analyzing by
uplc and of course
inline lcm lcms methods and we settled
on
using an overtrap with protein metric
software
and i gave really nice agreement to a
lot of these sort of slightly more
traditional
lots of established methodologies and
here we show
just an alignment between just mordy of
these isolated glycopeptides
through and the lcms and what this
enabled us to do
is have confidence to roll out full lcms
ignoring these more labor-intensive
methods
and this is the the methodology we've
been we've been using
what this has enabled is
plotting the carbohydrate processing
states
across the virus spike and this is again
hiv and you'll see in green these
mannose patches
that occur across the surface and also
hot spots of highly processed areas you
know shown in in magenta these complex
glycans
and areas where there's an intermediate
level shown here in orange
where there's a degree of um under
process a mixture of
mannose and and complex now we can also
extend this
to um you know looking at those
different
formats the monomers the pseudo
triangles and native light trainers
and understanding how on a site-specific
level
does the adoption of these native like
um native light folds impact
the processing states and plotted here
is a percentage point difference
so we're just doing um
just displaying the changes in the
percentage of oligomers between
monomer and trimer on the left and
pseudotrimer
and drama on the right and what this
indicates is where there's red
in the in the trimer there's been a big
increase in the amount of oligomers so
more
um limited amounts of glycan processing
and that's pretty similar in the triumph
the pseudotriumph as well just to
slightly
less lesser extent now this can be
rationalized
structurally because we have thanks to
kelly mormon and others
crystal structures of menositases and
this is from
the mormon lab in complex with elegance
so in cyan we have the outline of the
crystal structure of the
menosodes one in complex with its target
so this is a deactivated enzyme
in complex with its target and what we
can do is superimpose
that complex onto the hiv surface
and we see the extraordinary degree of
clashes with neighboring sugars
and in fact it envelops all three
neighboring sugars in this particular
case
and that also got important biological
consequences as well
because we know if we do knockouts or
the virus naturally
loses a sugar it doesn't always lead to
a big
impact on processing they often stay
oligomanos within the oligomenos patch
so that is also important when we
consider about epitopes
for boarding neutralizing antibodies is
that there is a certain redundant
redundancy built in to the system and
even if the sugars are appearing and
disappearing
it can have quite a minimal impact on
the processing state of these
surrounding sugars
but there does seem to be a bit of a
contradiction here is what i'm saying
that
mannose is appearing because it's not
accessible to enzymes and yet it can
have this wide ranging impact
on interaction with lectins and even
with antibody recognition
and here shown on the left i'll try to
put this on the same basis
we have the um the minosodase
you'll see entirely enveloping its
target glycan this is quite important
because
enzymes act against carbohydrates are
often pretty linkage specific
and they need to have quite extensive
recognition interfaces
in order to achieve that selectivity
and this is in complete contrast to a
lot of the lectins shown in the middle
where they can um recognize the tips of
sugars
and don't need to embrace them quite so
much and similarly with antibodies
they're capable of slotting as we've
seen before
slotting in between them and a variety
of different mechanisms
so really the the virus can be in a
situation where it's
um adding so much sugar that it can't
get processed by the enzymes
but it's totally accessible to electron
recognition
um and to to antibodies now what are the
implications
versailles kv-2 now um
that similarly has uh you know these
you know vile glycoproteins protruding
and you know as soon as
the outbreak became it became apparent
that this was
going to be a pandemic we began to
um go on a sort of chronovice response
level and i would really like to
acknowledge
the support i've had and we've all had
from um
our corporate partners including
including thermo
and of course the flexibility of our
funders
so which really enabled sort of slightly
outer program work
and this extended from explicit use of
financial resources
also the redeployment of of staff so
that's been
incredible so we've been not only
analyzing
immunogens vaccine candidates but we've
also been
generating glycoproteins to set up um
serological testing uh particularly with
the university of birmingham and the
company binding sites
so um yeah big thank you for everybody
there
so we first um
contacted jason mcclellan's lab at the
university of texas
and got hold of a sense of battery
protein
of his viral spike and also with the
expression plasmid so we can make it
locally
and our um our team i
like this slide because it it it shows
not only some
some happy students here so yasuo in the
middle who did a lot of the work and
also
joel allen with his summer
highlight a lot of the work in the
forthcoming slides uh but also
indicated our transition from the
university of oxford to university of
southampton and the hiv work i present
has actually
performed in the glycology institute so
what i'm going to be talking now is then
is our analysis of this
sars immunogen and i'm just going to
give you a little bit of just technical
technical information here just to
understand some of the language
so these um i'm going to be talking
about oligomeric glycans i've already
mentioned
and here i'm showing them with sort of
green mannose residues
and you'll see that they're attached to
two glutamate so we call those
oligomenos glycans
but you'll also see magenta the complex
glycans and this gets a little bit more
more involved but with the managed ones
we call them man nine referring to nine
manage residues command five and um
in contrast the description complex
glycans gets a lot more involved
and in this talk i'm going to be largely
simplifying it but basically you can
have multiple branches
a multiple antenna and so in the figures
you'll see when you talk about
a2 or a3 this is the number of atene and
branches basically
that the glycogen has and it's also
capable of having galactose or xylic
acid
we often simplify this by classing them
based on the number of branch points or
the fucosalation states
and i can just give you one example of
that um here
you get this by antenna is uh but with
potentially
without a biceps or with or without
fukes
and similarly you will see the odd
situation where we have hybrids where
the
mannose trimming hasn't occurred fully
and yet it can also pick up
um some of the features of more complex
glycans
and hence why it's referred to as hybrid
now the analytical methodology we we use
is obviously um using the the old trap
for the site-specific analysis of
glycopeptides we tend to do a lot of uh
offline
uh ups analysis of fluorescently labeled
glycans and we also do
quite a bit of characterization of
release glycans um
using a synapse and it's um these these
methodologies
uh we combine uh as part of our sort of
analytical workflow
we're focusing mainly here on the
site-specific analysis
where we adopt a very traditional
protamis approach
of you know trypsin and hemotrypsin
treatments
and again where the data i'm showing is
uh generated on the
trap fusion using protein metrics
software
so your many of you be aware we can
generate a
chromatogram of our glycopeptide signal
we search for peptides modified
with carbohydrates we identify
them um look at check for the isotope
distribution
we're checking for the fragmentation
signals again across different charge
states
we're then integrating the chromatogram
and
it's summing all those different forms
you know
um you know for example charge states we
sum all those together
and um and at that stage we can actually
begin to get a
really good quantitation showing in
these these bar graphs at the bottom
and this particular site taken from hiv
you can see heavily dominated
by by man9 now switching to
sars kv-2 i'm going to show more
complicated data
and this is what we tend to see and you
see all the different glycan
sites um and other bio i don't expect
you to
see it's just load numbers these are
different types of carbohydrates you can
see very complicated
one of the take homes here is that
glycosylation
is highly heterogeneous it is
complicated and it adds a big burden
um on investigators to actually try and
present the
work in a simple way and i hope we
go some way to achieve that but the
other thing i want to point out is
you'll see the eagle item once you'll
see error bars here
and this is actually data from three
different protein expressions
including one from texas and one from
southampton
um and it's remarkably stable so we can
consider
glycosylation as highly heterogeneous
and
tempting to say random but it's a
reproducible randomness
so you know that's a really important
take-home
now taking that complexity we can again
simplify these just looking at the
number of branch points and the few
consolation status
and you can begin to to see the
distribution
of sites which are presenting mainly
oligomenos glycans
and an extensive range of ones which
present in these magenta
complex and highly processed structures
and you're probably already noticing
that there's an
elevation of processing compared to the
hiv equivalent
i'm going to again map those processing
states onto the
priori m structure and um and you'll see
that unlike
in hiv we don't really have a a mannose
patches say with these very dominant
exclusively oligomenos sites clustered
together
we have snippets of that going on but
the the take-home messages is
largely processed but this
representation using this categorization
system
does lose some subtleties there because
if you put it on more of a sliding scale
of mana's
content you do see that it is presenting
some some manners and that's important
because
that degree of manas can influence
immunogen trafficking
etc so you know we are seeing a degree
of manners appearing so there is still
a bit of a deviation away from the
typical
mammalian glycosylation um
interestingly we do see the um features
targeted by antibodies against kobe 2
like the one identified that's uh
specific for the few coats
we can also plot the abundance of other
modifications
like fucos in the middle here and and
cylic acid and you'll see that inverse
correlation as you'd expect
where you know the sites which are uh
display less oligomenos are displaying
enhanced
levels of fucos and xylic acid but
taking the
the mannose level one step further we
can begin to compare across the you know
different
um viral classes now the three panels on
the left we have stars
the original stars kv-1 uh the data just
showed the
kv-2 mers and then i've for comparison
also included
uh lassa fever and hiv and you can
see that there's the coronaviruses are
actually landing
at the lower end of the spectrum here
so when we first thinking about this we
really um
you know thought the take-home message
here was that there was this
showed a degree of vulnerability that
this
these glycans were not as dense as um
as in hiv and this probably reflects a
different biology
like it's uh sort of hit and run virus
it's infecting things a bit like flu is
ripping through a population rather than
than having to
to stay uh where which is hiv's
um you know mo if you like
now we can begin to also relate this
processing
state that we can measure with um mass
spectrometry
to cryo-electron microscopy and this is
some
beautiful work uh formed by zack in
andrew ward's lab of
showing his email here and he's been
able to plot
signals using cryo-electron microscopy
of the carbohydrate
even if it's diverse and so you see on
the left
in hiv you have extensive reins of this
like connected network of
of signal you're seeing in cryo-electron
microscopy um
whereas you compare to the sars and this
is the sarsko v1
um you get much more isolated less sort
of regions of connected carbohydrates
so much more pockets of individual ones
again reflecting that slightly more
dispersed carbohydrates
less shielding and ultimately
quite an extensive range for antibody
recognition
so big areas of vulnerability
plotting that uh together we can look at
oligomani's abundance
across the vowel spike and um looking at
the
measure of glycan density and as you'd
expect there's a pretty
close correlation between increased
glycan density
and the appearance of these oligomenos
structures
now a lot of this i've shown has been in
recombinant systems and i tried to
reassure you
that they do capture many features of
the native virus
but that has been greatly enhanced
by the i mean just breathtaking work of
silly's lab
um in china and they've done some
beautiful work working with
authentic infectious
doing the cryoelectron microscopy
showing the architectures of not only
the spikes
but also the underlying nucleic acid and
as part of that work
they're able to analyze the
carbohydrates of the chronovirus
and here is a slightly different color
scheme but basically blue is the
oligomenos structures um you can see
that
again the chrome device is naturally
processed it's not
it processing isn't impeded by this
unusual budding pathway
and that where you get manners presented
in the conference system that is
captured to a degree
in the native virus now what's
interesting to know is that it's all
shunted down so there's more processing
and interestingly we see a similar
pattern
in hiv where um and this is again uplc
analysis
of virally derived gpr120 and then 2.20
from recombinant systems
and you'll see that whilst uh the
recommended system captures
the main features of the viral
glycosylation
there is a tendency to slightly enhanced
processing so what we can do is also do
that
on that site specifically and here um
the bar graphs are just individual sites
showing the amount of manners versus
knots and you can see the two structures
on the left
and the recombinant show extensive
oligomannoes
and in in the virus on the right
where you have sites of intermediate
processing these are generally driven to
completeness
so you still have oligomers features but
um the probably the longer residency
time has led
to increased processing but overall
what we can conclude from this is that
monitoring the glycosylation of
recombinant
material is really important in
understanding your immunogen
how to what degree it matches
the um the target virus and of course
to what degree could those modifications
influence the behavior
of your immunogen when used in the
clinic and there is a prospect
of engineering it artificially so that's
also a really interesting
line of research so this brings me to
thank the people that have been heavily
involved in the work joining the
great advice we interact with so many
labs across the world that
are in the uh i'm embarrassed to not be
even
able to include everybody but big thank
you to all our co-authors and
collaborators
i've highlighted here some people had a
particularly large influence on the work
presented throughout this presentation
and you'll see
in the picture uh joel allen um
saying hi to yasuo in a suitably
socially distanced way
so big thank you and to everybody who
listens today
and i very much look forward to your
questions thank you
thanks for that um excellent talk i'm
glad to see uh
somebody who's done glycowork in the
past the glycans getting a mainstream
at the moment so uh yeah it's really
excellent to hear your talk here so uh
we do have time for uh
questions so feel free to type in the
questions in the chat box
so the first question that i have here
is you mentioned
about the importance of glycan
processing but
how important is it that sites are
highly occupied
that's a very perceptive question yes so
um
in the one way of answering that is that
we don't know in many cases
um but we're getting a very clear idea
of the importance of that actually in
hiv vaccinations now
um what we see is because the density of
the sugars is so high
and often it's those regions where we
want to try and
tease out an immune response towards
when there are
sugars that are absent it creates these
sort of the
terms glycan holes and these turn out to
be
highly immunogenic now this is not a
good situation if you
recall back to the last slide where we
noticed that in hiv the occupancy
of the viral glycans is incredibly high
so the recombinant systems do often pick
up
um holes um it is largely we think
driven because you're making it
as a sort of soluble expression enhanced
version
um and there's a lot of effort in
actually re-engineering
um these hiv um primers so that they
don't have these holes so one uh line of
work that we've been doing with uh roger
sanders
one of durking joel allen to name a few
has been to try and re-engineer the
primary sequence
of the viral spikes in order to enhance
occupancy
now the occupancy rates can be
influenced
by the precise squad so in a simplistic
way
an x t is slightly higher occupied than
nxs
so one way is simply to mutate those
s's to t's and you do if you use that
approach
uh gave a high high degree of occupancy
interestingly because the density of
sugars and hiv in
the sort of primary sequence is so tight
um you know they you can have a
rapidly or they're so spaced so close
together
um it does create some complications so
if you over enhance
the occupancy of one you can have
detrimental impacts on neighboring
sites so actually what uh
you know particularly ronald has been
working on is
winding back some of this occupancy to
maintain
high efficiency throughout those regions
and
what we see working with andrew ward's
lab at scripps using cryorium
is that we can see those antibodies that
recognize these holes
being eliminated by this so that's
another example where
mass spectrometry measurements of
occupancy actually match
other structural biology um structural
questions but yeah
great question occupancy is emerging as
important in particular applications
definitely
thank you great thanks max um next
question here is uh does the
manos content change in different cell
lines such as
cho which is that's
a really important thing we get asked
this a lot
because obviously the uh yeah the cho
cells of chinese hamster ovary sales
are such an important platform for
production of biologics
whereas a lot of researchers uh can be
using the 293
f system for example so it's totally um
understandable to be concerned about how
those systems
are related um but one reassuring thing
is it depends on what you're trying to
optimize now in in hiv
and many of these viral glycoproteins
the mannose content
is really quite a key quality indicator
and quite dominant in terms of its
biology so
when we look at that the two systems are
highly similar
and it probably reflects the
evolutionary conservation of the enzymes
themselves
but you know actually the menosodases
are conserved
you know all the way throughout the uh
the eukaryotes basically
so um they behave very very similarly
now i would just add one sort of in one
other consideration here
and it's a bit bit subtle but you can
have manners appearing
in situations where you're expressing to
an incredibly high level and
so many of the audience be aware of um
the successes people have had in
production of antibodies where they now
can exceed a gram a liter
and you know in those types of systems
you can begin to get sort of product
inhibition so you're
hydra you know basically hydrolyzing
loads and manners off your
in this case antibodies and the manners
within the
within the er actually adds as an
inhibitor
so the manners can begin to appear in
certain situations when you get to
incredibly high yields
um but in these types of situations
they're all very
comparable so i should obviously not
leave it just on manners
um when you look at the complex glycans
they do change
effect quite a to to a large degree
so the degree of branching the level of
silic acid
you know all of these touch parameters
do move so depending on your application
it can be important so thank you okay
thanks max
um the next question is to what extent
does mass spectrometry data agree with
3d structures
of viral glycoproteins being determined
by cryoem
yeah that's that's a really interesting
one because um
i mean a lot of the structural biology
work that's occurring
uh is revealing uh the architecture of
carbohydrates now the last slide i
showed
was this um mapping of the carbohydrate
cloud which is really trying to take
signals
uh from almost like the disorder and
plotting
plotting the disorder and that gives a
sort of uh indicator of how these
sugars might be interacting but that's
quite a special case you used to study
these
um you know the wider heterogeneity
in many cases um structures have been
isolated
uh where um the reconstructions
revealing
the architecture of individual glycans
quite in quite amazing detail
now it varies considerably in some areas
where there's they're on
extended loops or you know they're
flexible you don't see that same
resolution by traditional methods um but
in cases where there's a high glycan
density
um or is bound in complex with the
target antibody
uh the macro electron microscopus and
even crystallographers
you know they both of those methods are
yielding um
very precise structures
of glycans now i actually showed in one
of the slides
um a complex of an antibody with the
target glycoprotein and that all that
was entirely by chris
christology and revealed all the branch
points so where we're saying
um sort of structural um
homogeneity uh we see really strong
agreement
and where mass spectrometry comes into
you know comes into its own is when it's
highly heterogeneous
and that's where we start to lose
information in
in some of the structural biology
approaches and where mass spectrometry
has
you know such a huge role to play so
thank you
thanks max our next question is is there
any evidence for
olin glycosylation in the current
coronal virus sars cov2
yeah that's a that's an interesting one
obviously i
what i've been talking about today is
heavily dominated by ending glycans now
there's a couple of reasons for our
emphasis
uh one is that there's an awful lot of
them and
um also that you can very easily see in
the primary
sequence their you know attachment
an attachment point is encoded o-links
is a very different
proposition there's no defined
attachment sequence so um
you can sort of broadly categorize into
two two areas
we have regions where which might be
o-link modified which are heavily
dominated by syrian students and
proteins we don't see that type of sort
of mucin like domain
within sars kv2 so what you got left
with are
modifications that occur on slightly
more globular regions or potentially
extended leaps
now uh we've uh did have a look in a few
places where
our data enabled us to and we saw
evidence of very low levels
of olin and other investigators have
found
um you know a similar story um
sort of low very low levels of
modifications
in places people do see more and some of
those methodological differences and
sometimes there's sample differences as
well
so the an important theme
is really it's very tempting to compare
the analytical endpoints
and to sort of weigh up who says there's
more or less um but
we also need to do the same level of
scrutiny on the the samples
and base basically different different
samples
uh with different um how do i put it you
know oligomeric states even
will tend to pick up different levels of
modification in
hiv um we've looked at one particular
area where
o-links have been reported and actually
see a
big elevation of that modification uh
in structures that are sort of
pseudo-trimmeric they're they're not
actually for adopting the native form
and when we express these stabilized
native farms the degree of only
modification drops
so yeah the jury is slightly still out
on this i think they are there
their role in their abundance is is
still being refined i would say
so thank you thanks max um is there a
role
sorry is there a biological role for all
the glycan heterogeneity you see
so it's quite
tempting to sort of um yeah understand
glycan
um biology by if you have a particular
sugar you're going to get a particular
effect
and you know hence why
we're so obsessed with that amount of
manners or potentially amounts of
particular cyclic acid linkages which
can have uh immunological
um impact the role of heterogeneity is
really interesting
i would say the big um when we look at
the wider biology
one thing is there's a massive
redundancy within glycosylation
so just because you see a particular
linkage and particular structures
in one situation doesn't always mean it
has a particular function
and famously you can do mouse knockouts
and knock out particular linkages
and you only see abram pathologists
picking up in
isolated areas in in many of these sort
of
terminal elaborations so you know
redundancy is a
heavy as a you know particular hallmark
of glycosylation
now in case of hiv and with other
viruses
there may be a role i mean one of the
advantages of heterogeneity if you're
being targeted by antibody recognition
is that it sort of dilutes down
the amount of epitapes you're presenting
and in the case of hiv
we see examples in neutralization assays
where an antibody that binds sugars is
incapable of fully neutralizing a
particular
particular viral isolate so that means
there's no genetic variation there but
there's variation actually in the virus
and sure enough that can be assigned to
variations in carbohydrate
um you know so the heterogeneity within
glycans
so it's a sliding scale of importance
you'll find examples where the
heterogeneity yeah
literally reads out in terms of its
impact on neutralization
and you'll have other examples at the
other end where heterogeneity is just a
byproduct of the
evolutionary selected pressures on
glycosylation
generally and potentially in very
different parts of the body and
different cellular systems
so hopefully that's not too elaborate
complicated answer to that question
you know that's perfect our next
question is
how can therapeutic target a native
spike protein
if the recombinant targets display
exaggerated glycosylation
that's an interesting one so
what we'd we'd first have to establish
whether
uh glycosylation the details of
glycosylation matter
at all um which is probably a
controversial thing to say having just
uh
sort of uh bit of about their importance
but um you know some some vacations may
be
particularly um potent without sugars at
all so e coli derived
rbd domains may be effective uh
and in certain settings so where
glycoscalation comes into play
is when you need to optimize something
that's not not quite working
um or you you know you can you want to
have an enhanced
form of the vaccine so you know
certainly second
second generation approaches this is
where you need to put your fuller
fill attention and there um you know the
details
will have it's slightly empirical you
know does the lack of
for example if you're making a protein
that has no manners on
um you know does that um limit its
the trafficking roots to actually
generate a
typhoon immune response that you you'd
like and the potency of immune response
you'd like so the degree of matching in
many systems is unknown
in in other ones like in hiv
you want to match
the epitopes actually displayed in your
they're targeted by your broadly
initializing antibodies and there
i would would say that the degree of
matching and where
where is their agreement and where is
their divergence
becomes important and thankfully many of
the antibody epitapes
targeted by boarding exciting antibodies
in hiv
target regions where there is agreement
rather than where there's divergence
so yes again it's a bit
specific to whichever virus you are
you're looking at
okay thank you um can certain
glycosylation profiles be an artifact
of specific expression conditions and
not endogenous biology
um well almost certainly so one of the
reasons why i emphasize
the mannose content is that's one bit
which tends to be
in close agreements not always identical
but in close agreement
as soon as you talk about other um
other elaborations you know then you're
very much looking at your
your sort of model system and you know
what you can learn from recombinant
material can be quite limited
so this yeah again it just emphasizes
where we try to take information and we
think it is informative
manners levels i think are are one of
those areas
and where we don't pay so much attention
to where we know that that's
you know uh gives you deep insight into
the behavior of
human embryonic kidneys and it has less
less relevance to those other systems so
yeah i think you need to use model
systems uh
eyes wide open you know they continue a
lot but they also have their limitations
and you know that's that's really clear
okay thank you max um you answered part
of this question so i'll ask the second
part which is the
viral protein so they display
o-glycosylation is it of
importance if you seo glycosylation
they are different from the typical and
glycosylation because there's specific
roles that they play
differently than something like so
yeah so let's just keep it um
more let's let's look at that within a
virus contact
i mean if you're picking up um
modifications
say for example around the protease
cleavage sites
um a lot of the proteolytic maturation
events occur
very late on in the secretary system so
if you're picking up only modifications
that are somehow impeding that
proteolytic event
that's going to change your you know the
the abundance
of your mature proteolytically yeah
proteolytically matured
product so you can you can envisage
scenarios where o-links do suddenly
become quite
important if you certainly if you see
them
in large abundance and other people
don't that may be a strong indicator
that
the protein conformations you're seeing
are sandwiched by more diver
diverse and flexible than many other
systems
so i think it can be a really important
indicator of the underlying protein
um integrity and conformational space
but it's it's clearly not always
negative they do they do happen in
in viral glycoproteins and they're meant
to be there and so
um yeah you have to be very careful
about the precise system that you're
you're talking about
and um and yeah they they contain
information basically
so yeah keep an eye on them great thanks
max
uh again thank you for this um excellent
talk and taking
time to answer a lot of these um
questions that came in
um just to the audience that are
listening in uh we're gonna
take a 30-minute break and we're gonna
come back about 30 minutes
past the hour where we'll have four more
excellent talks uh focusing around virus
research
we will also have a round table after
the four
talks that have occurred where the
participants
from this presentations will join our
moderator
andreas humer to have an extended
discussion around
virus research so again uh thank you uh
you know take uh
the next 30 minute break you know grab a
coffee grab a tea
then come back and join us for for more
excellent talks
thank you all and thanks max thank you